أظهرت دراسة جديدة من جنوب إفريقيا
أن الأشخاص الذين تعافوا من
متغير omercon قد يكونون أكثر مقاومة
للعدوى من متغير دلتا ،
الباحث الذي قاد الدراسة قائلاً إن
دفع دلتا للخارج هو في الواقع أمر
جيد ونحن نبحث في
شيء يمكننا التعايش معه بسهولة أكبر
والذي سيعطلنا بشكل أقل من
المتغيرات السابقة التي تنضم إلينا الآن هو
الباحث أليكس سيجل ، وهو عالم فيروسات
في معهد البحوث الصحية بأفريقيا.
دفع متغير الدلتا
بشكل
جيد ما نراه هو أن أه الأشخاص
الذين أصيبوا بأوميكرون
وبالطبع
في جنوب إفريقيا كانوا قبلنا بأسابيع قليلة
في هؤلاء الأشخاص نحن نتحقق من
مناعتهم لكل من omicron و delta و
ما نراه هو أنه نعم
إنهم يكتسبون مناعة ضد
omicron كما تتوقع ، ولكن أيضًا
مناعتهم تجاه متغيرات دلتا
تم تعزيزها الآن.  كانت الخبرة في جنوب
إفريقيا أن هذا الأوميكرون قابل
للانتقال بشكل كبير ، لذا أصيب الكثير من
الناس ، وبالتالي
فأنت تعلم أن المستشفيات كانت ممتلئة ولكن
لكل
شخص تسبب في مرض أكثر اعتدالًا
من البديل السابق الذي كان
دلتا ، لذا فإن تعزيز مناعة
دلتا قد يكون كذلك.  شيء جيد